Hello, everybody and welcome back to section seven of stop fighting cancer and
We're gonna dig into some other issues with cancer. So I have said for many years that I believe that cancer is
Has an autoimmune component to it. So I want to explain that a little bit today
So what is an autoimmune disease now?
By definition if you Google search autoimmune disease you're gonna see what your body is attacking itself tissue
Well, that's we really want to take place with cancer. We wanted to kill these
These cells that are gone rogue and to that are in a rapid replication state and are dying
We want them to kill that. Well, that's one issue that we have with cancer is that your immune system isn't initially attracted to
Your old cells that are in rapid replication
Because they are your old cells. So
So how does autoimmune play with that? So first of all with autoimmune issues
You need to understand a little bit about what the immune system is your immune system contains
numerous
Different chemicals different chemokines and cytokines and white blood cells and macrophages and just a bunch of different
Slurry of chemicals that are involved in two major processes. The first
Processing is is lumped together and what's called a TH1 response and the second process is a TH2 response
So I'm gonna simplify it greatly here
But for the most part your TH1 response are typically
The response of the killer cells. So they are the marine core with machine guns that are going to kill pathogens that enter the body
That's what we want to take place with
Cancer we want to increase in the TH1 cells
So anytime that you were would take a mute stimulant quote-unquote like garlic or vitamin C or
Acidacea
Stragolas or something like that that is a node of mute stimulant
It's really stimulating that TH1 side. It's it's army the marine core with machine guns so that they can go kill
the pathogens
Well, when a person has an auto-abute issue that is diagnosed as an auto-abute disease
Let's say they have MS or rheumatoid arthritis or Reyna let's sir or rosacea or something like that
It is typically a TH1 dominant disorder if it's aggressive
Beating that they have more killer cells out there that are armed that are then killing self-tissue
For reasons we won't get into in this little piece and
It's destroying their person's body so they're destroying neurons and they're having you know brain issues
They're destroying joint capsules. So they're having joint issues
That's typically a TH1 dominant auto-abute issue
So understand that an auto-abute disease leaves a person
either TH1 dominant and they get all these
Horrible symptoms or it can leave them TH2 dominant the TH2 side of the immune system is mainly responsible for making antibodies so that the TH1 side could go find out what it's trying to kill and kill it better
So the TH2 side is less destructive and it
It leaves a person with more of a chronic inflammatory process that a sudden acute inflammatory process that doesn't do a
ton of killing it just leaves with these inflammatory markers
Because of the TH2 side of cuts
So with cancer we really want a we want to stimulate a TH1 response because a TH1 response will help kill cancer cells
And we're gonna talk about that in later sections of this book and how to do that and what to take so that you can
Stimulate a TH1 response
However in this little piece we talk about that cancer typically at at least at the site of the cancer
The person isn't a TH2 dominance
Now that is important because that's what can help the cancer grow
We don't want to be in a TH2 dominance better. In fact
Cancer's growing cancer cells. There's much research on this now
Actually stimulate a TH2 response at the site of the cancer so they are
You're the cancer cells themselves are
Created cytokines that are decreasing
Your your own immune systems ability to kill it
So when I say all cancer is autoimmune I mean that it has an autoimmune component
The person could have had an autoimmune disease TH2 dominant for decades and not known about it
And that's what helped
Bring the person to be more susceptible to the cancer growing because their immune system wasn't able to keep it at bay
I mean their TH1 system wasn't able to keep it at bay
But also at the site of the cancer even if they didn't have this long
Standard autoimmune issue that was TH2 dominant they become TH2 dominant at the site at the site of the cancer
And we really do want to balance that there's some things that we want to do to balance that
So normally a person should have a balance TH1 TH2 side and when you're exposed to a pathogen
Your TH side TH1 side increases to kill that pathogen if it wasn't able to kill that pathogen after two three four five days
That the TH2 side fires for the purpose of making antibodies to that pathogen so that when that suppresses in the TH1 side fires again
It's able to kill that pathogen. That's a normal immune response
But with cancer you could get stuck in that TH2 excess
You're stuck in a TH2 dominant at that side of the cancer so your immune system isn't able to keep the cancer at bay
And it's growing so we want to bring that into balance and to actually fire a little TH1 in balance
So your hyper TH1 that's what we really want with the cancer patient
We want them to have that immutability
We want to arm the marine core with machine guns so that they can help kill the cancer
It's a very important piece when dealing with a cancer patient
So I spoke really fast
I know that watch this video again if this is all new to you
And read the section I think it'll be beneficial. We'll get into as we get into my favorite things here
We're going to get into things that many of them stimulate a TH1 response
That's why they work with cancer and that's why the danger of chemotherapy is that if it stimulates a TH2 response
Because chemotherapy is going to shut down your killer cells
So it just drops your whole immune system down so you remain TH2
dominant and
It's doing nothing to help your immune system kill the cancer
Well, of course your ecologist is going to say well, we understand that the chemotherapy is killing the cancer
But you need that immune system not just for the cancer. You need it to keep the circulating to your cells
From the test aside, so we don't want the test is this
with us, you know, and just because we want to kill this growing cancer right now and set this person up for
a
Huge metastasis two to three years later that now was chemotherapy resisted
So it can be worse
So you really need to stimulate a TH1 response even more so if you're going to
If you're going to be dealing with chemotherapy, but we'll talk about that as we go
I hope you're getting some of these things. I'm trying to keep them short
And always if you have questions feel free to call our office
And we can try to help you through these things
All right, you have a blessed day and I'll see you at the next six